good morning sir
um speak English correct yes you're
being charged Sir with brand theft
fraudulently using personal
identification
um intellectual property offense
computer users defenses against secure
users all right tell me about it State
give me the details so Mr Sabu had gone
into a Western Union on 8th Street yeah
and asked one of the employees there to
let him print something from their PC
and gave them a thumb drive to try to
accomplish that some drive wasn't suited
in the computer it started to act
erratically and the thumb drive was
moved and returned to Mr savu fast
forward a couple of days later he goes
into another Western Union and tries to
convince the employees there to do the
same thing this time the employees at
the second Western Union the actual rest
location feel that something is wrong
and reach out to police
thank you